ROBERT MARTIN: So I'm
Robert Martin from Google,
and I'm joined by
my friend Simon
Protheroe from Square Enix.
And today, we're
going to be talking
about unlocking the value
of data for your games.
So the first half
of the talk is going
to be primarily
around architecture
and around simplification
and scaling of analytics
for large global games.
And then the second
part of the presentation
will be Simon talking about
some of the really incredible
analysis that Square has
been doing around several
of their games.
So who went to the Stadia
announcement yesterday?
Or who watched it online?
Everybody excited about that?
We're very excited to
be adding another logo
up there to all the awesome
consumer services that Google
is launching.
And we're obviously most
excited about gaming.
So Google Cloud, in particular--
we view ourselves
as the hub that
joins a lot of those
other services together.
It helps you integrate
them and bring value
across all of those
different Google offerings.
And we have four pillars that
we're very passionate about.
Number one is Cross
Platform and Cross Play.
And the way that
we accomplish that
is by abstracting away
a lot of the technology
so that you can focus on
games and data and analytics
and ultimately,
customer experiences.
We also are very committed to
open source and open standards,
and you'll see
some of that today.
And that's pretty
different than what
you see in gaming solutions
that you can find elsewhere.
ML & Data Analytics--
obviously a strong area
of expertise for Google.
And we'll tap into that a
little bit this afternoon.
And I think that first slide
did a good job of laying out
that one Google picture, and
all the different ways that we
can help you.
So machine learning-- one
of the really interesting
challenges about
machine learning.
Everyone wants to take
their games into this realm
so that they can provide more
customized experiences so
that they can more effectively
monetize their games.
But it's really challenging
to unlock the insights
from your data with
machine learning,
because there just aren't
that many data scientists.
There's 21 million
of us developers,
but there's only about a million
data scientists worldwide,
and there's only about
several thousand deep
learning researchers.
And most of them
probably work for Google.
So when you're thinking
about unlocking insights
with machine learning, you
need to get the infrastructure
and the technology out of the
way of the data scientists,
and you need to bring developers
into that type of analysis.
And so if you think about
traditional data and analytics,
a majority of the time is really
spent supporting, scaling,
and tuning the
infrastructure that's
necessary to process
data at large scale.
So you actually spend a minority
of your team's time focused
on insights.
And at Google, we ran into
the same problem years ago,
actually, as we
tried to scale up.
And we wanted to flip
that equation on its head
and have our developers and our
data scientists spending most
of their time on analysis
and insights, and a minority
of time really thinking
about infrastructure.
That'll inform a
lot of what we're
going to talk about here today.
So this is Google's journey
through big data processing,
all the way back to about
2002-2004 time frame,
where we invented
distributed file systems.
And we also invented
the MapReduce algorithm.
So that, for us,
allowed us to unlock
all the consumer-level
data that we
were collecting with all of
our consumer facing products.
But we very quickly outgrew
MapReduce's ability to scale.
And so in 2008, we invented
a data processing engine
called Dremel that greatly
altered the path as far
as how we built a data
processing pipeline.
And we're going to
dig into that today.
So if you look at that
center lane on the slide,
that's essentially
Google's journey internally
to modernize its data
processing capabilities.
But along the way, I mentioned
we're committed to open source.
So we've been surfacing a
lot of that software for you
as open source APIs.
So things like Hadoop,
HBase, Apache Drill, and even
TensorFlow.
Now, the really
exciting part, I think,
about what we're doing
today is that we're
surfacing not only the
software as open source,
but all of that infrastructure
that we're using internally
to power it as Google Cloud.
And so we'll talk about
that a little bit later.
So what does a data
pipeline look like on GCP?
What do we mean when
we've abstracted
all the infrastructure away?
So if you've done
data processing
in a Hadoop-based
ecosystem, you're
familiar with a lot of
different programming models,
a lot of different
tools, and a lot
of different layered
solutions to try and achieve
real-time performance and scale.
When you abstract the
infrastructure away
and you write the solution
from the beginning for scale,
it becomes a very
simple picture.
So our data pipeline has
three primary components.
If you want to stream
data from a game,
you broadcast to
our global message
bus, which we call Pub/Sub.
Think of it as a global
serverless Kafka.
Then you need to take that data.
You need to transform
it into a shape that's
suitable for storage.
And that's what
we call Dataflow.
And Dataflow takes your
Java or Python code
and scales it up
as high as it needs
to go to process the incoming
messages from that data
pipeline.
And then the final
storage area is BigQuery,
and that's our serverless
data warehouse.
And that's what we're going to
actually focus on most today.
So three very simple components
that all scale and all require
zero infrastructure management.
So this is what the reference
architecture for a gaming
solution looks like built
on that data pipeline.
So at the center of
the picture, you've
got BigQuery, which is just
a data warehouse with tables
and views, like any that
you're used to using with SQL.
The primary difference
is how it can scale,
and we'll talk about
that in just a minute.
Up at the top, you've
got your game clients
and your game servers
that are streaming data
over to the right.
And we're ingesting
that data with Pub/Sub,
transforming it with Dataflow,
and storing it into BigQuery.
Now, you also need to do
batch ingestion in many cases.
You might have log files.
You might have chat
transcripts that you
want to drop off of your
servers or your clients.
And you can pull that in
in a batch methodology
through cloud storage,
also using Dataflow.
So whether you're streaming
or you're batching your data,
you're using the
same programming
model in both cases, and
the same scaling model.
So let's dig into BigQuery
a little bit more deeply.
This is where things get
a little bit interesting.
So if you're familiar with
traditional architectures
for processing data, you
have a collection of nodes,
and each node is generally
responsible for compute
and for storage.
With BigQuery, what we did is
we realized that couldn't scale.
Because sometimes, you have
massive quantities of data
that you want to store
cost efficiently.
And other times, you have
extremely complex queries
that you want to run.
And those two things don't
always scale together.
And in the traditional model,
you had to scale them together.
So the first thing
we did when we
designed Dremel,
which became BigQuery,
is we separated
compute from storage.
Now, you might say you just
broke the fundamental rule
of data processing--
keep data and compute
close to each other.
And so we couldn't just
separate compute and storage.
We had to connect
them back together
with an extremely fast network.
So we actually have a
petabit scale network
that sits in between our
compute and storage which
allows us to shuffle
data extremely quickly.
And we'll talk more about
that in just a minute.
So there's some pretty
exotic technology
that's powering BigQuery.
But the interface to
it is the same SQL
that you can use in
MySQL, or SQL Server,
or Postgres-- whatever
you're used to.
So we also store the data
in an interesting way.
So BigQuery is a
relational database.
Generally in a
relational database,
rows and columns of data
are stored together.
Because we have that
petabit network,
we can take the columns
in your database
and break them apart as well.
And that allows us to do some
interesting things as far
as how we process the data
and how we optimize the data.
So we take the best
of NoSQL databases
and apply that architecture
to a relational database.
And that petabit
network allows us
to take columns from one
table, or from multiple tables
that we're joining, and put
them back together very quickly.
So we process a lot of
sensitive data at Google.
Think of your Gmail
documents, and Drive
documents, and Sheets, and
all the metadata associated
with that.
We would never store your data
without high-grade encryption.
And so in BigQuery, that
same high-grade encryption
is available to you.
Each one of those
columns is actually
encrypted with a
separate encryption
key, which is, in response, also
encrypted with a key encryption
key.
And we rotate all of
those keys for you.
So the encryption
piece is there,
but it's also
abstracted as well,
so you don't have
to worry about it.
So we've talked about the
architecture of BigQuery.
You might be saying to yourself,
this sounds pretty cool,
but it sounds a lot like other
things that are out there.
One of the things that I want
to really communicate today
is the scale of BigQuery.
So when you think
about BigQuery,
this is not just a cluster
that's running in a data center
BigQuery is the
data center itself.
Our data centers are built
around the capability
to deliver data at scale.
So when you create a
dataset in BigQuery,
there are actually
three facilities
like this that are
managing all of the data
that you're storing.
Your data is replicated
automatically to all three
of those facilities.
Well, you might look at that
picture and say, all right,
Robert.
So there's still just a cluster
running in there, right?
It's a big building, but there's
a cluster, and that's BigQuery.
I want to give you
a specific example
of what I mean
when I say we build
our facilities around BigQuery.
So remember I mentioned
that petabit network?
A petabit is a million times
faster than a gigabit network.
How did Google create
a network that's
a million times faster than what
you generally see out there?
This is how.
So to build a petabit network,
we took 100,000 10-gig E links
and combined them into a fabric.
So this picture shows
you a small piece
of that fabric that's in each
one of those three facilities.
This piece of
equipment is the length
of a football field in each
one of those facilities.
That's what allows us to shuffle
data back and forth at scale
on petabyte-size datasets.
One other thing I want
to talk about briefly,
and then we're actually
going to get hands on here
and take a look at what
BigQuery can do live.
I want to talk a little
bit about machine learning.
So not only has Google
built purpose-built hardware
to store and process
your data, we also
have built
purpose-built hardware
to build, train, and run
inference on your machine
learning models.
Now again, why did we do this?
So there are GPUs out there.
We have GPUs in
our data centers.
Why go and build custom silicon
to train and run predictions?
The reason is simple.
Again, it's scale.
We need to be able to
constantly iterate.
So if you've ever used something
like Smart Reply in Gmail,
you might notice
that it just seems
to get better every few weeks.
And that's because we're
allowed to-- we can constantly
iterate and retrain our models,
because the silicon that's
built specifically
for machine learning
is 15 to 30 times faster.
So faster is good.
But also remember that
most of our products
that are consumer
facing are free.
So it also needs to
be cost effective.
So we get 30 to 80 times
the operations per watt
as we would get on a GPU.
That means less power
consumption and less heat.
Now, how do we do that?
How is it that this
chip is so much faster?
Well, if you think
about a GPU, a GPU
is designed to
perform one vector
operation per clock cycle.
If you think about training
a machine learning model,
you're working on matrices.
So if you want to do a
matrix operation on a GPU,
you have to iterate across
every row of that matrix.
So that's multiple clock
cycles to effectively perform
one operation.
Our tensor processor units
are matrix processing, so
each tick of the clock, we
can process an entire matrix
operation.
So that's how we're
able to train faster
and more cost-effectively.
And so now I'd like to
jump into the console,
and we'll take a quick look at
what BigQuery can do at scale.
So I just happen to have a
petabit of data laying around,
and I thought we might run
a couple of SQL queries
on a petabyte while I'm up here.
So this dataset
is 1.09 petabytes.
We have a trillion rows
in this table, stored.
And we're going to
run a SQL query on it.
So the first thing I
want to do is, in case
you haven't worked with
BigQuery, let's take
a quick look at the structure.
So BigQuery is just like
any relational database.
You have tables
that have columns.
So we have a set
of columns here,
just like you'd have in MySQL.
We've got familiar ANZDATA
types here, so very familiar.
When we talk about
simplifying the interface
and empowering your
data scientists,
this is what we mean.
This looks like a
typical SQL database.
So let's take a quick
look at the data.
So this is a preview
here, but you
can see that the
data is arranged
in exactly the same
way that it would
be arranged in any database
that your data scientists have
been using.
So we're providing a
really simple interface
to some very powerful
infrastructure on the back end.
So that's cool.
That's a quick preview of what
a table looks like in BigQuery.
Let's go ahead and take a
look at what running a query
looks like.
Let's see if I can zoom
in here a little bit.
You can see this
query a little better.
All right, so we're going
to do a SELECT query.
We're going to do a SELECT query
on the sales partition table.
Again, it's a trillion rows.
We're going to round and
sum one of the columns.
We're going to do a
group by, so we're
going to be
aggregating the data.
And we're also going to be
sorting all of that data,
on all trillion rows.
We're also going to be doing a
search for a specific customer
key.
And because we don't require
you to do things like indexes
in BigQuery-- in fact, they
don't even exist in BigQuery--
we're going to do a full
table scan on a trillion rows
when I run this query.
So I'm going to zoom
out, and let's go ahead
and kick this query off.
So I just say "run query."
And our query is going
to start processing.
Now, let me give you an idea
of what's happening here.
So we're going to go and select
those two tablets for those two
columns that I'm querying,
pull them out of storage,
and we're going to shuffle them
across that petabit network
to the compute nodes.
The first thing the compute
nodes are going to do--
it's got two tablets
that it has to decrypt--
all trillion rows in each one.
Then we're going to decompress
the data at about 4 to 1.
So the data is going to
get about four times as big
as it was in storage.
And then our worker
nodes are going
to look at the
instructions in the query
and begin executing those.
And so that's what's
happening seamlessly
as we're processing this query.
If I was to do a SELECT
star on this same table,
it would run in about
the same amount of time,
because we just scale the
workers out horizontally.
And that's happening
automatically.
So this isn't going
to take long to run,
but I'm a little
bit impatient, and I
like to spend my time
doing productive things.
So let's jump over
and do something else
while we're waiting.
So I'm going to show you
BigQuery's ability to train
machine learning models in SQL.
So if you can see
this query, this
is another dataset that I have.
And this contains
birth data for babies.
And we're going to
build a model that
will allow us to predict
the birth weight of babies
based on some characteristics
about those births.
Now, this could be
useful for a game,
but you could just as easily
use the same technique
to train a player lifetime
value model or a player toxicity
model--
same techniques.
So let's take a look here.
The first thing I'm
going to do is just
a standard query to pull
the attributes that I
want to train my model
on, as well as the label
that I'm trying to train.
So I'm going to pull a
few items about the birth,
and then I'm going
to pull the weight.
Standard query.
Now, to train a
machine learning model,
I have a bit of
additional SQL up here
that says take the
output of that query
and feed it into a
linear regression.
So let's go ahead and
kick off a training job
on this linear regression model.
And so again, the same
workflow is happening here.
BigQuery goes out, calls
the data up from storage,
shuffles it across
that petabit network.
And now, instead of
performing query operations,
those exact same workers
are adjusting weights
on all of those input
variables to optimize
the performance of that
linear regression model.
And this should finish up
here in just a few seconds.
OK, so we're done.
27 seconds-- we trained
a machine learning model
on four gigs of data.
So that's step one--
training the model.
Step two for your
data scientists
is evaluating the model, right?
So we need to see how well
that iteration of our model
performed.
Maybe we need some
additional input
values to be able to
accurately predict baby weight.
So again, I'm going to run
another vanilla SQL query here.
Let's pull up all of the values
we fed into the training model,
but now with a bit of additional
SQL up here at the top.
Let's ask BigQuery to
evaluate our model performance
on our predicted baby weights
versus the ones that are
stored in our training dataset.
This will just take
a few seconds here.
OK.
So now what I'm
going to show you--
we get some nice
statistics back.
So our data scientists
want mean squared error,
and they want r
squared, because that's
what tells them how well
this model is performing.
So in this case, we've got
an r squared of about 5%.
We've got some work
left to do to bring
in some additional data
points so that we get really
nice, accurate baby weights.
But I've got the information
that I need immediately
to make those adjustments.
So the final step in training
our machine learning model
is running predictions.
So to run predictions with
our fully-trained model now,
we run a SQL query that simply
pulls up the input values
to the model, and
our predict function
will return our
predicted baby weights.
So let's run that real quick.
And this should only
take a few seconds here.
OK, so we processed four gigs
of data there-- five seconds.
And we returned 220,000
predicted baby weights.
So in the amount of time that
it took for me to start up
a SELECT query on
a trillion rows,
we were able to train,
evaluate, and run predictions
on a machine learning model.
So this is what we
mean about getting out
of the way-- getting
the infrastructure out
of the way of your very talented
and very scarce and in-demand
folks on your team.
Let's go check back in on
our trillion row table scan.
And it's done.
It ran in about two
and 1/2 minutes.
We processed 32 terrabytes
of data on those two columns.
And here are our total
sales, aggregated by day
and sorted for us.
What do you think?
Not bad.
That would take a
pretty big Spark cluster
to be able to do that.
You probably wouldn't want
to pay the bill for it.
So let's jump back
over to our slides,
and I'd like to close
by talking a little bit
about a customer that has
taken the full journey.
And that's King.
We actually have published
a whitepaper with them.
They have taken full
advantage at scale
of this infrastructure.
And what I mean
"at scale," they're
processing 50 billion
events per day.
So you might be
saying to yourself,
that scale is amazing,
but we're not there yet.
What I would say to you is,
everyone needs simplicity.
Who would want to have to
spend their time managing
infrastructure if
they didn't have to?
And number two, scale is coming.
So mobile and console
are converging.
The scale of mobile data
is coming to console.
And we also have hyper-casual.
It's a new, emergent
genre which generates
massive quantities of data.
So you need the
simplicity today.
And even if you don't
have the scale today,
tomorrow the scale
will be there.
And it's coming
faster than you think.
So at this point, I'd
love to introduce Simon
from Square Enix.
And he will talk about some of
the really fascinating analyses
that they're doing from the
business side on their data
with BigQuery.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SIMON PROTHEROE: Do
you have the clicker?
ROBERT MARTIN: There you go.
SIMON PROTHEROE: It's over here?
Thank you.
Great.
Well, thanks, Robert.
And thanks to Google
for the opportunity
to tell you a little
bit about what
we've been doing at Square Enix
for the last couple of years.
Hopefully, Square
Enix doesn't need
much of an introduction
for a GDC audience.
In case you're new
to the industry,
we're one of the leading
developers and publishers
of games across the world.
We're known most for
big AAA franchises,
such as "Final Fantasy," "Dragon
Quest," "Kingdom Hearts," "Tomb
Raider," "Space Invaders."
But we actually have
a very broad portfolio
of games on pretty much
any gaming platform
and any business model.
And that's something I want to
talk a little bit about today.
A little bit about me.
I joined Square in--
well, I joined Eidos as
a small startup in 1993.
And at the time,
we were six guys
in a boathouse on
the River Thames,
about a mile upstream from Henry
VIII's palace at Hampton Court.
Things have obviously
changed quite a bit
in the last 25 years.
And I've spent most of that time
in a number of different roles
within first Eidos,
and then after it
was bought by Square Enix, in
a number of different roles,
really looking at the boundary
between business and technology
development, and where
new technology enables
us to grow our business into
new markets, new platforms,
new business models, and so on.
And that's how we
end up today, looking
at what we're
doing with big data
and how we're addressing
that kind of challenge
I happen to be the guy
that's standing up here
talking about this.
There is, if not a
cast of thousands,
a cast of dozens
of people behind me
that have contributed
to this work.
Very little of it is
actually my hands-on typing.
There's tiny bits of code.
The guys try to keep
me away from anything
to do with production
code these days.
But we've got a
very strong team,
both on the data
engineering side that
have built this system, on the
analytics and insight side,
looking at working
with the data,
and then working across the
company with game teams,
marketing teams, brand
teams, and so on.
I'll try and mention
those as we go through.
But anybody I forget,
then my huge apologies,
and I'll buy you a beer later.
So if we look at what
we're doing with big data,
we've got a number
of challenges,
both business and technical.
Both Square Enix and
Eidos have been collecting
data in a very determined
way for about 10 years,
since before Square
bought Eidos.
And although we've
been collecting
data in a concerted
way, it hasn't
been in a particularly
organized way.
So what we've got
is-- or what we had--
is a lot of silos of
data of different kinds.
We had a lot of game
telemetry, but that tended
to be grouped into
different types of games--
games developed in
Japan, games developed
in the West, games
using one technology
suite versus another.
Some games, the game
data was entirely
held within the game team.
Others it was centralized.
But really quite fragmented.
And then we had a
lot of other sources
of data around our customers--
web analytics data, showing
their interaction with us
across a range of different
websites-- the Square Enix
website, but also individual
game sites, and so on.
Any interactivity
with our CRM system.
If you click on an
email or open an email,
that data is logged
and tracked, but again,
in a separate system.
Similarly, purchase data,
social media interactions,
registration data--
a whole bunch of
different sources of data.
And they were all stored across
a number of different teams,
by different people, using
different technologies.
Some of it, for example,
was in a third-party system
like Google Analytics.
In some cases, it was in
a SQL Server database.
In others, Oracle,
and others, MySQL.
Sometimes it was sitting
under some guy's desk.
Other times, it was
in a data center.
But it was really a
pretty fragmented picture.
And that led to a number
of technical challenges.
So about five, six years ago,
we started trying to pull this
data together-- at least, the
game telemetry side of it--
and build what was at the time
a state-of-the-art solution
for being able to
analyze that data.
We had a large on--
well, not large, large.
But a, for us, large on-prem
Hadoop cluster in a data
center in Montreal.
It was using licensed
software, licensed per node.
And that gave us a challenge
that we didn't really have
the scalability that we wanted.
To increase the capacity
of that kind of cluster
meant adding in a whole node.
And that was roughly
$20,000 or so.
So it wasn't a trivial
business decision
to add a node to that cluster.
And that was pretty much a
one-way scaling operation,
as well.
Once we scaled up,
we were committed.
We bought the hardware.
It was an annual license
fee for the software.
So we weren't really
able to scale back down.
So if we weren't
convinced we were
going to use that hardware
for more than a short term,
then it was very difficult
to justify making
the investment in scaling.
In parallel with that--
so we were running
at-- most of the
time, we were running
at capacity with whatever the
capacity of that cluster was.
Occasionally we
would scale it up,
but we were running at capacity.
And it meant the
data engineering team
spent all their time
spinning plates or juggling
fiery chainsaws or something
like that to try and keep
things from falling over.
They were optimizing the way
in which the data was stored,
making sure that we
were evicting old data.
And the problem was that they
were spending all their time
managing that cluster
and managing the data,
rather than actually do anything
that was genuinely of value
to the business.
And also, that demo
from Robert a minute ago
was fascinating, because we
just couldn't do something
like that.
We weren't able to--
we had data scientists.
Again, very talented guys,
who were really keen to
do a lot of experimentation
with machine learning models.
But we just couldn't do that.
We couldn't take a
large volume of data
and throw 1,000 calls of
CPU at it over 48 hours
to do some massive training
job, because we just
didn't have the resources.
So what we wanted to do was
to completely reboot our data
handling infrastructure.
A colleague of
mine, Tim Ward, who
heads up the Analytics
and Insights team,
spent a lot of time going
around the whole business,
speaking to pretty
much every stakeholder
from all the teams across the
business, all the locations,
at various levels
of the organization.
And we put together a
pretty comprehensive list
of requirements.
And a few themes
came out of that.
The overall top vision that
we're aiming for is what we
call a "single-gamer view."
By analogy with
retail FMCG companies
that have
single-customer views, we
wanted a single-gamer
view that gave us
a holistic view of a
gamer's interaction
with us across everything
that we could capture.
So gameplay data on a
range of different formats,
commercial data, marketing data,
social media, and everything.
But pulling all of that
together and represented
by a single identity
so that we knew
that this person on Facebook
was that person on our email
database.
This player on Xbox
Live, that guy on Steam,
this guy on Nintendo Switch.
So pulling all of
that data together.
And there are a few
other lower level things.
So the first is this.
The big driver for this was
that we needed it to be scalable
in a cost-effective
way, to enable
us to do that business
experimentation that
was difficult for us before.
We also, given the lifecycle
of a game and the way
in which our game
teams worked, we
wanted this to be a very
flexible solution-- something
that we weren't
setting in stone today
how that data has to look for
the next three, five years.
During development, game
schema will often change.
The types of data that you
want to collect changes.
We'd also potentially add
additional sources of data.
As the game is
released, and you've
got DLC drops, and continue
the evolution of the game,
you will, again, want
to be able to flex
the data that you're capturing.
And that goes for other
sources of capture, as well.
So we wanted to be able
to augment that data
and to process it on
the fly without having
to tear down pipelines and
rebuild them and so on.
And finally, pulling
all of that data
together represents a
huge opportunity for us
from a business perspective.
But it's also obviously a
pretty significant risk.
The more data we're
bringing together,
the more we're
exposing ourselves
to the risks of data
which was previously
anonymized becoming PII,
because we're connecting it
all together.
And it represents a
pretty high-value target.
So we now need to make sure that
we had the internal protections
and controls around that
data, and governance policies
around it to keep
our data protection
officer happy and smiling.
So spoiler alert.
We ended up partnering
with Google Cloud.
Which, can I have that water?
Excuse me.
No big surprise there.
But it wasn't a
foregone conclusion.
Once we'd gathered all
those requirements,
we then spent some time with
all the major public cloud
providers, and a number of more
bespoke specialist companies
that offered solutions--
in some cases tailored
to games, in some cases
more single-customer
view type solutions.
We brought them in.
We sat them down.
We showed them our problem,
talked a little bit
about the current
challenges we faced,
and asked them what
they could do to help.
And we had a number of
different approaches.
Some of them were, we
can build this for you.
We've got a professional service
organization full of experts,
and we can just give
you a solution to this.
And that's explicitly
not what we wanted.
We ended up going
with Google Cloud,
to cut a long story short,
for a number of reasons.
As Robert's pointed
out, the technology
is stunningly excellent.
On the network side,
for example, we--
as part of-- we build
proofs of concept
on a number of those platforms.
Obviously, there's no point
in doing a proof of concept
for scalability if
you're just working
with the amount of data you can
copy around in a spreadsheet.
So we were using not
petabytes of data,
but tens of terabytes
of data as a test set.
And getting that data into
the vendors' architecture
and moving it around was
lightning-fast with Google.
It was really not
a challenge at all.
It took a couple of
hours to upload the data.
And then once it's in GCP,
it's pretty much instant
to move around.
With some other vendors, it
took many, many hours, sometimes
even a small number of days.
And in some cases,
we never got there.
So just the fundamental
basics of the architecture
knocked us out of the
park from day one.
The other thing is
that for us, Google
felt like a good cultural fit.
And I think that's probably come
into a lot of games companies.
We're completely happy with
guys turning up in t-shirts
and just talking
tech from day one.
We're actually less
happy with people
turning up in smart
suits and giving us
polished sales presentations.
Not true for every industry.
But for us, the people that
we met at Google, from account
management through tech support
through solutions engineering
and so on, felt like a
good match for the teams
that we had, and the kind of
people that we had on our side
working on this project.
And finally, it
felt as though this
was something that they were
going to help us to build,
rather than something they were
going to build and sell us.
And that's a really
important point.
Of course, the fundamental thing
that we build is great games,
and that's--
our business lives or dies
by making fantastic games,
obviously.
But that is becoming--
over time, that is
becoming to be not enough.
We need to have a
transformational approach
to the way we handle data.
And this represented a big
strategic platform for us
to do that.
And so it was really
important that we felt
that we had ownership of that.
We've got some
phenomenal engineers
on the team who worked on this.
A couple of them are
here today, but there's
plenty of others back
in London, LA, Montreal,
who have worked
on this platform.
And we wanted to feel that those
guys owned this platform, that
understood it, and
that we weren't going
to be relying on third-party,
external companies
every time we needed
changes or something.
We needed to feel that
this was something that we
had control of from day one.
And the other point is that
the Google platform in general
felt very integrated.
There are other providers.
Some of the platforms felt
a little bit disjointed.
With Google, we
didn't feel that.
That was actually a
bit of a surprise.
The engineering team
originally, I think,
were a little bit
concerned when we
started looking initially at the
different providers' offerings.
The feeling was, well,
GCP doesn't really
have enough sliders and knobs.
We can't really control it.
It's a bit of a black box.
What we came to realize
during those initial concept
phases was that actually,
that's the strength.
And a huge amount of work has
gone on behind the scenes,
as Robert alluded to earlier, to
make sure that from our point,
it is a black box that
just kind of works.
So we've got-- the
controls that are offered
to you as a developer
are the ones you need,
rather than just all the ones
that they could make available.
And that's been a tremendous
advantage over time.
There have been a
couple of occasions
where it hasn't
quite been enough.
So for example, the previous
version of Dataflow,
which is based on
Apache Beam One,
didn't allow us to
migrate schema on the fly,
so we couldn't-- as data
came in, if the data came
in wasn't matching the
schema in BigQuery,
we basically had to restart
the pipeline and rebuild.
We worked with Google on that.
Explained the problem, they
came up with solutions,
and we found that we had a
solution when Dataflow moved
to Beam Two that will allow
us to migrate data on the fly
without restarting everything.
So there are occasions
where it's not
quite everything you need.
But there, that
engineering-led culture
really made the difference in of
getting us over those hurdles.
But in general, having things
as a closed box that just works
has been tremendously useful.
Somebody once made the analogy--
one of the Google sales team--
that it's a little bit like
Apple consumer products.
You think about the iPod when
it first came out, compared
to MP3 players at the time.
Lots of them had lots of
menus and screens and so on.
And suddenly, Apple comes out
with something with a screen
and little wheel and that's it.
And it turns out to be the most
awesome consumer experience.
And that's the right thing.
So I think there's
an awful lot of work
that it's easy to
overlook that goes on
behind the scenes on the
GCP side to make sure
that from a consumer's
perspective,
a consumer of the
engineering services,
that it's what you need.
So to cut a long story short,
we partnered with Google.
We, using their
reference architecture,
built a solution which
looks very similar to that.
This is ours.
If you remember the slide
that Robert put up earlier,
this is a very similar slide.
We've got live streaming
data coming in from games
and some other sources.
We have some on-premise,
some other data
that's coming in in Batch.
So in some cases, that's
some games that are still
sending overnight play logs.
We've got other
sources of data that
are ingested daily, sometimes
even less frequently than that.
That data is coming in.
The batch data goes
straight, basically,
into storage straight through
Dataflow and into BigQuery.
Streaming data is
published a Pub/Sub,
and then Dataflow subscribes
to that and captures the data
and puts it into BigQuery.
On both sides, Dataflow is
doing the data validation,
augmentation,
sanitization, and so on.
I'll come onto a
couple of other things
where we use Dataflow
as well, which
have been nice additional
benefits that have really
helped us out of a hole
with some other problems.
And then within
BigQuery, the data
is controls, in terms of
access, at a project level.
So we have a number of projects.
We have two projects,
actually, per game,
with different users
assigned to each project.
And then there are other
projects, and things
like sales data and
general datasets
that go across everything.
And we're able to control
at a quantifying level
who has access to what data
and what they need it for.
Similarly, on the visualization
and reporting side,
obviously we've got BigQuery
in the middle there.
We've got a number
of different users.
We have general business users--
people who basically just need
to CKPI dashboards.
May be able to drill it
in, or compare this month
with last month or something.
But they're looking at
dashboard-level stuff.
We have been using
Power BI for that.
These days, we're using Data
Studio for that much more.
When we first started working on
this project, Data Studio was--
quite frankly, it
was wasn't really
there compared to Power BI.
It has caught up very
rapidly, and we're
now very comfortable
with Data Studio
as a kind of visualization
tool at the dashboarding level.
Similarly, for Power users who
need to slice and dice data
a bit more, we
were using Tableau.
We're now using Looker,
another Google partner which
allows people to basically
do the same sort of things
they would use in Tableau to be
able to slice and dice the data
and do more complex things than
they can do in Data Studio,
without having to get down
and dirty with SQL queries.
And then of course, we
have data scientists.
We've got some of them.
You haven't got all of
them, but we've got a few.
And they are using traditional
data scientists tools.
We've got Jupyter Notebooks
with Python scripts,
and they are writing SQL.
And then we do have a little
bit of Cloud ML and TensorFlow
as well.
And those guys are able to get
access to the data in the way
that you've just seen
Robert demonstrate.
So one final concern.
I mentioned earlier the data
governance side of things.
Remember, this has been going
on for the last couple of years.
And if you cast your mind
back to this time last year,
everybody was very
concerned about GDPR.
We'd actually been,
on our side, planning
for that for about 18
months before last May,
making sure that
we were prepared
for the additional burdens
that were going to come to us.
We had a number of requirements
that the old system
couldn't meet.
In particular, it
was very difficult
for us to respond to a
subject access request.
If somebody wanted to know
from us all the data that we
held on them--
if you remember, it was
very, very fragmented
with lots of people,
lots of data,
and it was very difficult
for us to put all of that
together and return
somebody a readable file
with, here's all the
information we have on you.
It was possible, but it
meant a lot of phone calls
and CSV files being
copied around.
And now we forgot
to ask Fred in IT.
Also, we could opt out of things
like email marketing and so on,
but we weren't easily able to
stop collecting an individual's
data.
And another
requirement under GDPR
is that you can
collect the data,
but you can't processes it.
So you're not allowed to use
it for targeted marketing
and so on.
And that's something we
couldn't do before, either.
And finally, you have
the right to have data
that you can prove
is incorrect amended,
or to ask that your data
is completely deleted.
And both of those, we
couldn't really do.
The Hadoop-based
approach we had before,
the data was pretty
much write-only
from our point of view.
So if we had to
remove a user's data,
we would have had to
copy all but that data.
So you just drop the old--
just cumbersome and not
really operationally feasible.
So we had a bunch of challenges
that we had a legal obligation
to comply with that our
old system couldn't meet.
That actually was the thing
that tipped this over the edge.
So the data science team
had wanted something
like this in place
for a long time
to make their lives easier.
GDPR was the thing that finally
gave us the business driver.
We're going to have
to spend some money.
to do a bunch of work
to get to where we need to be.
Why not just build a system we
know that we need and we know
that we want, rather than
just try and patch up
the old system in some way?
If we have to spend
the money anyway,
why not spend it
in the right place,
rather than just spending it
patching up an old system?
So the new system--
all the data is in one place.
Implicitly, we have pointers
to where it came from.
So if we do need to find
additional sources for deletion
or something, we can.
Remember, all the
data ends up in SUV,
but that's not necessarily
the only place.
There are operational databases
that will have other copies.
And also, we were
able to increase
the level of governance
we've got around our data.
So one of the things that
we have been able to do
is to separate data
which contains PII,
and to provide additional
views of that data
with the PII masked.
Now, some people will
need the real raw PII.
Imagine customer service if
someone phones up and says,
hey, look I paid for
this item in game,
and I didn't get
it in my inventory.
Customer service
need to actually
have the PII to
speak to that person
and verify they
are who they are,
go into their game inventory,
figure out what they've got,
and resolve the problem.
But most people don't
need actual customer data.
They just need to
know, for example,
that these players are
unique, or that they
can do a join across
tables, and make sure
that this gameplay data is
matched with that identity
data, without knowing who
that person actually is.
So the way we did
that is, I mentioned
that we have two projects
within BigQuery for each game.
What we have is one which
contains the raw data, which
is very locked down, and to
which very few people have
access.
And then we have another, which
has an identical set of schema.
But any PII columns
in the original data
are represented by hashed
versions of that PII.
So it's unique, but it's
not personally identifiable,
unless you know what
that hash function is.
And the hash function is rotated
every week, automatically.
So from our point of view, even
if somebody takes an extract
and has a snapshot of what
that mapping is, in a few days,
it's going to be obsolete.
So we're limiting our risk.
There's not zero risk.
You can't-- you have to live
with some level of risk,
assuming you're not going to
completely distrust everybody
in your company
to work with data.
But we're able to manage
the risk appropriately.
People that need the
data have access to it.
People that don't
need the data, we're
able to protect them, to
be honest, from having
to worry too much about it.
So onto the results.
I'm going to talk briefly
about four experiments
that we've run with the
data since we started.
The first is targeting
some Facebook ads
for "Shadow of the Tomb Raider."
So what we did here--
and this is some
phenomenal work.
My team worked on the
actual segmentation
and lookalike audience piece.
The analytics and insights
team built the actual segments.
The marketing team
at Eidos Montreal
did a fantastic job
in the creative,
that we'll have
look at the minute.
And what we did
was we identified
six segments in our--
this is "Rise of
the Tomb Raider,"
so the previous version of
the game-- previous iteration.
We looked at the data
that we had for gameplay
of "Rise of the Tomb Raider."
We segmented that user base
using a number of attributes.
We'll look at them in a minute.
And then we had a number
of different creatives.
We had six 30-second
TV spots that we used.
We combined that with a bunch
of different copy lines as well,
for different calls to action.
And we multivariates--
it says A/B tested here.
It was actually
multivariate testing
to find out which creatives
resonated best with which
segments of the audience.
So these are, roughly
speaking, the six kinds
of players that we identified.
We've given them all nicknames--
Veteran, Action Junkie,
Solver, Dabbler, Completionist,
and Trialist.
There are obviously numeric
values underneath this
that we're using to produce
those segmentations.
It's not a straight binary
slice in three dimensions.
We've got actually a number
of different attributes here.
There's a cluster
analysis process going on.
Some of these are obvious.
We've got things like
gameplay and hours
of gameplay, percentage
completion, and things
like that.
Some of those, obvious--
if you look at these
descriptions on screen,
you can tell what
some of those were.
There are others that are a
little bit more sophisticated.
So for example, Action Junkie.
Takes risk
frequently, attempting
challenging obstacles--
that's one of the measures
that contributes to that.
None of these are simple.
They're all kind of
combined measures.
But one of the measures
that contributes to that
is what the UK legal system
calls "death by misadventure."
So if Lara doesn't make a jump,
or falls off a cliff edge,
or drowns, or is killed
other than by an NPC,
then we regard that as
adrenaline-fueled lust
for challenge or something.
So that's something--
the percentage
death by NPC versus
environmental catastrophe
is something that color
codes for Action Junkie.
So you've got those
different segments there.
And what we've done is the team
put together six, as I said,
six 30-second spots.
They're not a one-to-one
match for those six segments.
There happen to be six in each.
That's kind of coincidence.
These spots-- I've got--
I'm not going to
show all of them,
but we've got a 10-second clip
for each of them at the moment
that I'll show you.
Things to watch out for
when you look at-- there's
a little caption we can see.
It says "TV Spot"
on the right here.
That tells you what the
theme of that clip is.
They've also got
very different music,
and a different feel to them.
So if we run through that--
and then I'll talk a little
bit about it in a second.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Do you realize the
tragedy you have unleashed?
- What have I done?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- [GASPS]
[GRUNTS]
[RUMBLING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CAMERA SHUTTER]
- Because I could
not stop for death,
he kindly stopped for me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CLICK]
- By taking the key, you set
the Apocalypse in motion.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SIMON PROTHEROE: So
you can see, we've
got a number of
different clips there.
They've all got a very
different look and feel.
Some are darker,
some are lighter,
some have got more
upbeat music than others.
There are some which
have dialogue and focus
on the character or
the storyline-- others
which focus on stunts
and things like that.
And the idea was to
look at the segments we
had of the different
types of data,
and basically to
match those clips,
and figure out which
resonated better.
And then also, as
I said earlier,
the copy lines that we
had on the ads as well.
And give me one second.
Oops.
Yeah.
Sorry.
[CHUCKLES]
It's the one thing we
couldn't get working.
Thanks.
So to cut straight
to the results,
we found that the
segmented ads--
on average, the
segmented campaigns
performed twice as well as
the unsegmented campaign.
So we had some
benchmark campaigns
that we'd run before,
where we'd addressed
pretty much the same audience
with the same creative,
but with the same creative
across the whole audience.
The click-through rate
was on average about
literally almost exactly double
across all of these campaigns
combined.
Some performed even
better than that.
Some a little bit
worse than double,
but the average was double.
So we're really happy with that.
The other way of looking at it,
of course, is cost-per-click.
So we've either doubled
our click-through rate
or halved our marketing costs
for the same number of clicks.
So phenomenally successful
from our point of view.
Again, this is early days.
But the early
indications of what
we're able to do with the
data that we couldn't before
have been really useful.
Remember before, we
had that siloed data.
We weren't able, for example,
to take the siloed data
and match that to Facebook
data to build Facebook
audiences, which we could now.
Next, this may not look--
you might not be able to
see the detail on this.
But basically, this is the
"Kingdom Hearts" website.
"Kingdom Hearts" came
out earlier this year,
and we had the website
user journey there,
which is fairly traditional.
We've got a straight
landing page,
and then there's a user journey.
You can imagine going through
the history of the franchise,
details about this particular
game, and then a Buy Now page.
This was built by
the team in LA.
Did a fantastic
job on the website.
But what we wanted to
do is try and make sure
that we were getting
maximum use out of that.
And again, looking at segmenting
the audience for that.
We've got sources
of data for people
who were completely new
to the franchise, where
starting on the landing page and
stepping through that journey
is the right thing to do.
We have other people who
have got a high purchase
intent already, that dropping
them straight into the Buy page
is the right thing to do.
But equally, if you get
that the wrong way around,
the last thing you
want to do is take
somebody who's ready
to buy and bore them
by taking them through a
whole history of the franchise
that they already know.
Or for somebody
who doesn't really
know much that has just
heard about this Pixar thing
that we've done, and wants to--
maybe they've picked
up some marketing
on the Disney side of
things, and doesn't know much
about the game--
dropping them straight in a Buy
Now page feels really abrupt.
So what we did was look at
the sources of the traffic,
analyze previous root
results from those sources,
and then have the--
basically, the consumer
dropped into that user journey
from those ads at what we felt
was the right place for them.
And this performed even
better than the "Tomb Raider"
campaign.
We got click-through rates
increased by 144% here.
Click-through is
to retailer links.
And overall conversion
increased by 20%.
So again, really happy with
the results from that site.
A couple of others that I'll
touch on very briefly before we
talk about next steps.
With "Life is Strange 2,"
which is an episodic game,
we localized into a
lot more languages
than we did for
"Life is Strange 1."
"Life is Strange
2," we saw that we
had users in new markets
like Russia and so
on, but the game itself wasn't
localized into those languages.
So for "2," we localized
into those languages.
And what we wanted
to do is measure
the effectiveness of that.
We can't necessarily just
look at sales data and say,
we sold double the
number of units.
We need to look at other
data as well, user the data,
where people are
playing the game,
correlating that with
purchase-- because obviously,
they will be in different
markets, other than--
there are sources of
gameplay other than people
just buying their own copy.
There's lots of
second-hand, there's
piracy, and so on as well.
So understanding that
helped us really figure out
how we were going to
optimize our localization
spends in future.
So having done
this, what we found
is that that
localization effort,
having analyzed the data,
using the data in BigQuery,
we can find that we've
got, in some countries,
double the share of
users for this version
than we had previously.
So that's share, not
absolute numbers.
So the indication there is that
localizing to those languages
has really had an
impact on increasing
take-up in those countries.
And finally, timing
analysis for episodic games.
This is something that
we're doing at the moment.
The work's ongoing.
But what we're trying to do
is look at improving our sales
forecasting, and
eventually get to the point
where we can actually control
our sales curve to some extent
by affecting the timing
of episodic releases.
For some games,
some players will
be super excited about a
game, and pre-order a release.
For other games, they may
play the first episode,
and then buy a season
pass to enjoy the rest
once they've bought in.
They're treating the
first episode as a trial.
Player C there--
maybe those people
are buying the collector's
edition at the end.
Or perhaps they-- maybe
they've played the whole game,
maybe they haven't,
but they're buying
much later in the sequence.
But then you've got
potentially Player D,
which is a group we didn't
get at all, who maybe played
the initial free first episode,
and then just dropped out
of the process entirely.
So understanding
what that looks like,
how those player
bases segment out,
and how the timing
of those releases
affects that is something we're
doing at the moment in order
to improve not only our
forecasting in the short term,
but long term, the ability to
actually control that sales
pipeline.
So some basic examples there.
I think as we've
said, we've now got
to a situation where there's a
lot more experimentation going
on.
A lot of those constraints
that we mentioned earlier
have gone away.
We've been really
happy with the results
that we've got
from the platform.
We've got a really solid
relationship with the GCP team
where we feel we're getting
a lot of support where
we need it, and fantastic
tech to build on.
We have worked on a number of
the challenges that we had.
For example, the
Schema migration,
and got great results there.
We have a happy, smiling DPO.
I would have shown you a
picture, but that's PII
and I'm not allowed to do it
without written consent, so--
But we're comfortable now.
We're a lot more secure than
we were in our governance
around the data.
And this is the first
real cloud native
application that we've
built. We had infrastructure
in public cloud before.
We had web servers
deployed on Kubernetes
in different environments.
But we hadn't
really taken a leap
and built anything cloud native.
What we were doing really is
infrastructure as a service,
so it was effectively just not
paying for the hardware CapEx.
But this is the first time that
we've really got into that,
and it's been
incredibly successful.
So what's next for us in
terms of the single-gamer view
platform?
Well, to torture
the Pokemon analogy,
we've got some
legendary data sources
that we still want to catch.
There are some games which
aren't yet in this system,
for various reasons, and we're--
having got these
initial proof points,
we're now able to bring
some of those data sources
in and open up
those conversations.
A year in, we've also
got some good use cases
where we can justify automating
or building further tooling
around the platform.
So things like we mentioned
earlier, the ability
to filter users and to either
capture or not capture data,
or to process or not process
data, and having that process
automated.
The API-driven is something that
we're working on at the moment.
We're looking at a
cross-platform segmentation
framework, so the
sort of segmentation
that we did for
"Tomb Raider," we're
able to have those segments.
At the moment, those segments
are extracted out, and then
used to build audience lists
for Facebook and so on.
With the cross-platform
segmentation framework,
what we're intending to do is
have the segmentations native
to the system itself so
that we can pass them
around as first-class objects
within the architecture.
And finally, all the
examples I've given here
have been marketing related, or
maybe sales analysis related.
The reason for that is twofold.
First of all, my team
is responsible for most
of those websites
and stores and so on.
So it's within our team's
ability to do those controls.
We work very closely
with the analytics team.
And between the two of us, we're
able to do this without too
much additional buy in.
But the other
thing, obviously, is
that the dev cycle on
a marketing campaign
is weeks or months at most.
The dev cycle on a game
is months or years.
And so it was going to
be much quicker for us
to get those kind
of proof points
by working on
marketing campaigns
to show the idea--
the proof of concept
of what we want to do with
user data and segmentation.
But the next step for us
is then closing that loop,
and starting to use
that data from BigQuery
natively in games to
do personalization
and so on within
the game itself,
rather than outside the game.
And what's next?
So that was what was next
for the SGV platform.
What's next for Square
Enix in general?
Well, we are deploying
game servers on GCP
for some multiplayer
titles coming up,
which is going to
generate a lot of data.
We are also deploying a lot
of the back-end services,
so our identity systems,
billing systems,
store sales, and so on are
being deployed in GCP as well.
Again, it's going to
generate a lot of data.
And finally, we're scaling
up analytics pipeline,
the SGV platform itself, to
be able to cope with much
larger portions of data.
Fortunately, of
those three pillars,
that's the easiest
for us, because that's
something that pretty much is
handled entirely by Google.
So the scaling side
of it is something
that is no longer a
big challenge for us.
We just have to write a
slightly bigger check.
That's fine.
And that's it.
I don't think we'll
have time for questions.
I've left my email
address there.
Feel free to get in touch
if you've got any questions,
or come up afterwards.
But otherwise,
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]